this is Startalk the whole model of
education as information transfer makes
no sense makes no sense right and you
thought about this you founded you you
co-founded a university a brand-new
University in Canada and I hear you're
at it again in some other place where UK
in the UK just tell me what you would
cuz you didn't just come out of nowhere
out of a cave to say this hmm you pull
you you you did it
what did you do and are you being sued
by the New York Attorney General okay
now go ahead that's the other guy oh
okay um well yes so the idea is instead
of feeding people information you have
them construct knowledge construct their
own knowledge out of what they know and
a little bit of guidance shoving them
down a path takes much longer much
harder it's much harder it takes much
longer you know doesn't matter if you
don't have to transfer all this
information much longer and harder I'm
going to take you up on that because I
I'm not sure if I understand what you
mean when you say construct your own
knowledge okay I'll give you a good
example we're strong we can talk about
astronomy yeah yeah of course yeah yeah
yeah so when we discover all these
planets around other stars right and
that's that required exoplanet that's
amazing right it is twenty years ago we
knew no planets except ours now we know
so how do we do that well we have to
know how planets move so Kepler figured
this out in 1610 you know figured out
how planets write down three laws of
planetary motion so a Columbia I go to
the blackberry write down the three laws
of planetary motion and my students all
copy him down even though it's sitting
in the under fifty dollar textbook next
to them and then I say how long has take
the earth to go around the Sun right and
they sort of look at me and finally
someone says a year and I said well
let's see if that works and you plug in
the numbers of the period and the
semi-major axis of the inputs and they
write all that down and then you send
them home and they do it for how long it
takes more to go around the Sun right
and you know then on the test you make
it real tricky and say how long take
your oppa to go around Jupiter you know
and Intergraph to change the mess but
they get their age and they go away and
they're happy that's just feeding
information to people that's yeah all
right so that takes 20 minutes at Qwest
question the name of the University in
Canada right it
three hour classes five days a week
three hours a day I walk into class I
give them this little simulation about
planets going around other stars 15
parameters they don't know what any of
them are okay I give them a sheet of a
few questions
let's say look see what this see what
happens if you change this and keep this
one fixed okay I figure out what this
means here and then I'll um play a two
and three and a half hours later they
stayed a half hour after class someone
got up and wrote down Kepler's three
looks I never mentioned Kepler never
mentioned three locks that's they had
constructed they're looking amazing so
therefore they will not be susceptible
to being handed information I others
right now they won't remember Kepler's
law I don't remember Kepler you remember
cut the process matters but the process
they remember you can look at look at
information you can look for patterns in
it you can cast those patterns in a
mathematical form you can use that to
predict away something else behaves and
that's all you want and you're testing
and those are tools that's a toolkit for
learning how the world works and
construction for biology and chemistry
hey did you like that cool video huh
well how about a bunch of cool videos
all commercial-free plus exclusive
original content that you can't find
anyplace else all on Startalk all access
com